i don't do a lot of interviews like this
so there's not a lot of people that do
get to see this side of me chris
eubank
jr
the biggest fight of his life growing up
i was always chris eubank son a lot of
people would say you're trying to steal
your son's limelight to a certain extent
maybe he was i have to do something here
to where people know me for me
i got myself into this gang some kid had
gotten my number
he was like wait till i find you i went
into school with a baseball bat to find
this kid i take the baseball bat out
that changed the path of my life
[Music]
the first time i went to dubai there was
a young guy there and offered to train
me
that was your brother
i just started crying man it was you
know one of the worst days of my life i
knew my brother was in dubai and i
didn't go and see him
that would have been the last time i
would have saw him before he passed
um
a man named nick blackwell he got taken
to hospital he actually died on the way
to hospital he had to revive him with an
adrenaline shot those types of incidents
are what put things into perspective and
make you think about what you're doing
have you ever had this conversation with
your father about your emotions
this is too much
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
chris
one of the really remarkable things
about your story that i was
that kind of broke the mold a little bit
was someone that comes from a family as
you described where you did have comfort
because your father was very very
successful in his career
it seems like a little bit of an anomaly
that you had such
discipline
and appetite for
struggle and pain because usually that
comes from typically stereotypically
that comes from
a background of intense hardship
so i guess where my question is like
where did that come from in you and is
that
something you saw in all of your
siblings
i always had that
very competitive
uh
personality you know and before i found
boxing
i was heavy into sports in school
cricket rugby football athletics
swimming um
and i i just got a high off of
competing and winning
just
just competitive that's all i all i want
to do was test myself against other guys
and then obviously when i found boxing
i
quickly understood that this was
the ultimate form of competition
you couldn't get anything
more intense more hardcore
more pure
than
two guys putting gloves on getting into
the ring
and
and going until somebody can't go
anymore
did you have
that from your dad at all was he ever
pushing you in those early years before
you even knew he was a boxer to be
competitive to win and that that was
important or was it more just
innate in you
you know it's funny my father actually
he was the opposite in terms of
supporting or you know pushing me
towards boxing
he he banned me from going to boxing
gyms for a couple of years
he didn't think i'd be tough enough you
know so uh you know i was begging him
all the time let me let me go to the gym
let me let me let me go and spa let me
go and train
and he he would just tell me no no
you're not going
stick with your athletics stick with
your rugby stick with your football
stick with your studies
that was a big thing for him you know
because he didn't have that education
growing up
um
boxing's gonna be too tough you know
you've got so many look at look at where
you are you're in a mansion you go to
private school
you know you've got everything you need
and want here why do you need to go down
to the gym
and and get your ass kicked every day
so um you know it took years of me
nagging and begging let me do it let me
do it
um
finally he gave in
and i guess the rest is history now
we're here
when i was younger i remember my older
brothers could all eat really spicy food
and remember someone saying to me at the
table maybe one of my brothers maybe my
mum she was like don't give that to
steve he can't eat it when i heard that
it sounded like a challenge to me
now when you said that about your dad it
almost sounded like a dare it sounded
like a challenge did you receive it like
that him saying you're not tough enough
to do that absolutely you know as a kid
um
when you're told you can't do something
you want to do it
ten times more do you think he was aware
of that
he's a smart man
you know what i've never thought of it
like that i've never thought about that
like was he
was he trying to bait me you know was he
saying this or stopping me so that when
i actually did start i would go so hard
that i would actually you know make
might make something of myself in the
sport i have no idea
if he did then that's that's a hell of a
you know a thing
but um
no i mean i i genuinely think that he
he did really think i wasn't tough
enough
i mean world champions the best fighters
in the world
generally come from
poverty from hardship from broken homes
and they fight because they have to
fight
there is there's no other option for
them if they don't win if they don't
succeed in boxing they don't eat
you know they don't have a home to go to
they can't pay the bills
um
so that's what fuels them to
to make it they have no choice
uh whereas me i had
i have many choices so in a way
i see it as i i see it as actually more
of a
an accomplishment
because i didn't have to go through
everything i went through to get to
where i am today
34th of fights 32 wins
the pain the hardship the sacrifice the
suffering i didn't have to do any of
that
i could have
stayed in school i could have
kept the rugby up all the or the or the
football or the cricket
um
you know and i i would have made it in
any sport that i wanted to make it in
i know that
why
just just because of my passion and my
my drive you know once i once i zone in
on something i want to do
nothing else matters
and i will i will do it and i will get
there
by any means necessary
people that don't know about boxing or
don't know how to fight
they think that you got to be big and
strong and mean and full of hate and
that's what
enables you to be a great fighter or to
be able to to win in the fight game
and sure some of those things are going
to help you you know speed power all of
that stuff
plays a big part for sure but the
biggest part
of being able to be a great fire is is
this
and a lot of people don't realize that
or don't know
that it is
in my opinion
i don't know 70 80 mental
you know
the balls and the the grit that you have
to have
to
you know walk through crowds of that
thousands of people
and while you're walking there knowing
that you know once you get
to that ring and walk up those stairs
you're gonna have to take off your
jacket
the bell's gonna go and you're gonna
have to fight somebody
you're gonna have to get hurt and you're
gonna have to hurt somebody in front of
thousands of people and millions of
people around the world
that in itself
that that walk
most people on the planet could not
cannot do that
just the walk let alone the fight part
it takes a lot of mental strength
it takes a lot of of guts a lot of heart
you know mental strength
it's a huge thing in boxing
it's a big thing in life
even outside of boxing right in business
and
in all i think great endeavors do you
think it's something that you can from
what you've seen in the gym something
you can teach or train
i think you can have you seen it talk to
someone that didn't have it
i've seen fighters
improve
you know i've seen fighters over the
years become more confident and
in their abilities and you know
that does transfer for that just
transfer over to their performances in
the ring
i think to a certain extent you do have
to have
that strength that that belief and that
courage and that
that mental fortitude to fight
it can be enhanced
in some ways
but only to a certain extent
because at the end of the day
there are going to be times
in training inspiring and definitely in
in the fighting
where you're going to get hurt you're
going to be in a position where
you're questioning yourself
what am i doing here
am i gonna be okay can i beat this guy
um
should i give up should i find a way out
this is too much
every fighter experience is that that
that moment you know have you
experienced that yeah in a fight
there's one time where i was close to
giving up
one time
i went to cuba
before i turned pro
out there obviously they have the
olympians and
you know their their olympic
training is second to none you know
these guys are animals they're monsters
um
in cuba they have this thing called
technical sparring which i had never
done and i never did
ever again until maybe up like two years
ago
but technical sparring is basically um
you're sparring but you're not aspiring
to hurt the guy
you're aspiring to work on technique you
know so it's like an agreement all right
listen i'm not gonna go all out here you
know we're gonna work on the jab today
or we're gonna work on foot movement
um we're not trying to bang each other
out
you know they they they're big on that
they're big on technical sparring
i had never done anything like that my
my whole mentality was if i'm going to
spy you
i'm going to try and get you out of
there
because that's how my mentality is going
to be when
i'm in a real fight
so i i need that's just how i need to be
um
the cuban
olympic heavyweight representative
walks up the stairs and gets into the
ring i thought he was coming into the
ring to to shadowbox and warm up for his
sparring session with somebody else
he said no no you guys you guys are
going to spa
i was like
uh
dude he's
about three times the size of me what do
you mean he's like yeah yeah it's okay
it's okay we you know he'll work with
you he'll work with you
technical sparring
so i thought sure that's fine let's go
first round goes first bell goes this
guy
sprints over to me
and just starts
laying into me the biggest shots
bang bang bang
head up moving out the way dungeon
running around the ring and he's just
coming at me and i can't get this guy
off of me
he knocks me out of the ring he punches
me i i fall out of the ring i drop down
it's like a three four foot drop onto
concrete
my knee hits the hit hits the concrete
my leg goes dead
right
this is the second round that this
happened i still have one more round
afterwards
so i'm getting up
legs completely gone
i'm looking up
in this heavy weights like leaning over
the the ropes looking at me looking down
at me
and i have a decision to make
do i get back in
or do i say listen my knees bad you're
too big
i've got a concussion let me know let me
just take a break
so i'm sitting there i'm looking around
everyone's looking at me my dad's there
i was like you know what let's [ __ ]
go let's go walk back up knowing knowing
what i was about to receive once as soon
as i got back in the ring
and that's like what happened
crack click uh you know clapped us back
in
just starts laying into me again for
another another another two rounds
but my whole thing was
i have to finish the three rounds
why
because i said i was gonna do the three
rounds
i said i would bar him three rounds
i'm not leaving this gym
with everybody knowing that i quit
why not
why not because uh
i couldn't i couldn't live with myself
i've gotta i've gotta go home and go to
sleep
how am i going to go to sleep with that
on my mind you know i can go to sleep
with getting my ass kicked by a guy
who's three times bigger than me i can i
can sleep like that
i can't go to sleep knowing that he
another man made me quit made me run out
of the ring no
so i got back into that ring and i took
my beating like a man
and from that day on i was never scared
again
so that was the worst
experience of my life in terms of
boxing but it was also the best
experience
because i knew
i knew what i was capable of i knew i
had it inside me to not give up
i knew i could take a shot
i knew i had what it what it would take
to make it if he can't make me quit
who's gonna make me quit nobody
so that stuck with me for the rest of my
career
something really interesting which i i
gained from that
which is like we basically create a
personal like philosophy or story with
ourselves and in that moment when you're
looking up at stepping back into that
ring with that massive guy in there
it's like you're you're writing or
making a
story about yourself one that will
probably follow you forever and i think
about this sometimes when i'm on my own
and i'm on my like peloton and i'm
either exhausted or knackered and i know
there's seven minutes left and i know i
can just get off it but this thing in my
head goes but then steve you're changing
your own
personal story which is that sometimes
steve quits when it's hard
and the thought of having to live the
rest of my life with that per and it
sounds like a very strange thing i've
never said before but the thought of
having to live with that personal story
that personal philosophy that that's who
i am is never worth getting off the bike
because okay it's seven minutes today
but it's a lifetime
of thinking that's who i am and it
sounded like that in that moment you you
had a choice about who you were going to
sit you know and it's a self thing i
know there's other people there but
sometimes when i'm sure you have it in
the gym or whatever where no one's
around it's just
you and you yeah you have a decision to
make about who who you are right
happens a lot in training i imagine as
well right no that that's actually when
it happens the most you know there are
times you know i'll be i'll be on the
treadmill
where i'll be running and you know i'll
get a cramp in in the uh in my calf
yeah i've still got eight minutes to go
because you said you were gonna do
because i i've set the timer for 40
minutes on the thing
so i'm on i'm on 32 minutes
the cramp starts going
you're on the treadmill yeah
you got
you got eight minutes to go
and i'm i'm running like this now
but i'm not getting off the treadmill
because i've got to do the eight minutes
why no one's there nobody's there
but if the treadmill can make me quit
what happens when i get into the ring
with a guy who's hit me and i'm hurt
yeah he's gonna make me quit too so i'm
i'm on that treadmill for eight minutes
like that
just try and just try and not try not to
get the pressure on this leg
but i'm finishing the 40 minutes
now that is
you know it it's huge because
it teaches you
to believe and to know that you know no
matter how hard things get you will find
a way
you'll find a way
it doesn't matter who's watching you
know you know because
yeah no one's around right now so no one
would know if you took that break
but what happens when you're in a
situation where the world is watching
and you're in that same position of pain
or of
of un you know uncertainty about you
know
so you got a big speech or you you know
some something's happening and
everyone's watching and you don't know
you don't really want to keep going
you know
then you'll get that same feeling you
know what i'm going to do it
not
oh well listen i'm i'm i'm done i just
this is too much you don't ever want to
put that
uh
that spirit inside yourself you know
you got to you got to keep those demons
out
you know and they are demons you know
and if you and if you let them in
enough they take over
i don't let anything like that inside me
i always beat
what it is
uh that's in front of me what it is
whether it's mental whether it's
spiritual whether it's physical
um
i always make sure i come out on top
one of the ways we learn about who we
are and i was i guess that self story
that i was talking about there is by
looking at others we can sometimes
compare ourselves to our peers or those
around us or whatever it might be and
say
i know that i'm
different because everyone around me
isn't like this thing they're not like
they don't have this trait or quality or
think in this way that i do
when i look at your career and what
you've done it is remarkable because
as you said you had so many other
choices but you chose what i consider to
be
the
most tumultuous
struggle-filled one
and so i when i when i sit here i go
what is it about you
that's made you where you are today in
this this great champion
the character traits the attributes what
is it
i've always had a strong mind i've
always had a strong soul
i've always known what i wanted to do
uh and that i was never gonna stop until
i did it
um
i had a lot to live up to
you know growing up
i was always chris eubank's son
you know from an early age i was like
yeah but that's not my i'm not chris
that's not my name
my name is chris he made it even harder
by calling me chris he made it even
harder this guy
um
but i knew that that's not i couldn't go
the rest of my life
as that as just being the son of
oh that's chris you know i have to do
something here
to where people know me for me
that was a big driving factor
becoming my own man
doing something that people would be
proud of and that my family would be
proud of and that i could say was my own
now some people would say well then why
did you go into boxing with which is you
know the same sport your dad did
um
you know it's a good question i mean
i guess that
you know
i guess that competitive
uh
soul inside of me maybe
wanting to see if i could be better than
what my dad was
see if i could be better than the guy
who said i i wasn't tough enough
um
i'm sure that was
in my mind in the early stages
now that i've done so much it's it's not
at all you know i don't ever compare
myself to my father people do all the
time you know who would win in a fight
if you you and your dad fought or you
know did would you ever spar with him
um i don't i don't think about any of
that you know
i just have to be the best fighter i can
be um
because at the end of the day
um
especially in boxing you know
you know you you're only going to be
competing with yourself that's how you
that's how you elevate that's how you
get better
not by focusing on other people and i
think that that goes for you know any
industry if you if you're constantly
looking at other people and what they're
doing and
you know
why they made it or why they didn't make
it you know you
you're losing out on on you and what you
know and on what is best for you and how
you're going to progress
i never looked up at anyone and said i
want to do that and i want to be there i
just i always just thought to myself you
know what
this is going to be so hard as it is i
don't want to put any added pressure on
myself
i don't want to you know
can i can i get as many wins as my dad
or you know can i be more famous or make
more money like
all that stuff would it's just it's a it
just messes with your mind so you just
have to focus on day by day
week by week fight by fight
just being the best you can be and
that's what i did and i just built that
up over the years
until you know until i had made my own
name and made my own
uh
path um
my father's always been there he's
always been there to support me and
guide me
i think
he's now taking a back seat a lot a lot
a lot more than he was originally he was
frightened and said at the beginning of
my career you know
you you look back on youtube at the at
the the press conferences and the
weigh-ins he was right there
you know and he'd be talking on my
behalf sometimes
a lot of people would say you know oh
you you're trying to steal your son's
limelight um
to a certain extent maybe he was or
maybe he
i don't think he was doing it
consciously like oh i want to i want to
steal a sunset but it's just
he's such an entertainer he's such a
people person he just couldn't help
himself
you know he'd have to get up in the
middle of a press conference and do some
poetry
or or talk [ __ ] to my opponent or he had
to he just that's just who he is
um
and early on i actually didn't mind it
because
i was so hell-bent on just becoming
a good fighter
i didn't even really want to talk to the
public
and i and i i always got and i still do
get a lot of
uh
trolls online social media
so it gave me like kind of like a bad
taste
for
publicity and and media and and
so i didn't really even want to deal
with that i just wanted to fight i just
wanted to get my record up so that
people could start saying okay yeah this
kid's a bad boy that's all i cared about
so it was actually him he actually did
take a a lot of pressure off of me by
him kind of doing the talking for for a
certain amount of years
um
now that i'm established
now that i am you know where i am in the
sport
uh
that isn't needed
you know i'm 32 years old now i can't
have another man at my press conferences
speaking on my behalf it's just this
it's just not gonna fly
so for the last few years
he hasn't been doing that
i'm comfortable in front of a camera now
i wasn't comfortable at the beginning
in the beginning i was very and i looked
back and i looked back at the all these
pictures i used to take with fans and
interviews and i was always very
serious and stone-faced
and not
fun to really listen to in interviews
and people would say oh yeah i met you i
met you uh you know i met you in in 2013
2014. look look here's a picture and
then and then and i'd be sitting
standing up some like this
what was that you just
you just had a bad opinion of that
no i just i was just so serious i was
just so obsessed with boxing like
and
for me when i'm in the fight i don't
play
you know some guys you know they they
walk they walk in into the ring you know
manny pacquiao's and joshua's in the
high-fiving guys and smiling and
you know dancing to the music
i'm not that guy i can't i can't be like
that if i know i've got to fight
i'm a barbarian
you know i'm it's wartime
um
and even though i'm light outside of the
ring now
as an adult
one even now i i still want this fight
time i'm not smiling
i'm not a nice guy
now as at the start of my career i guess
i couldn't i couldn't separate
the fighter from
the guy in the street they were the same
guy
so whether i was in the ring or i was
taking a picture with the fan
i i wasn't smiling i was a serious dude
now
as you get older you you know you
understand you can't
you can't be like that around
normal citizens
because it's
it's it's just weird you know you you
have to be able to smile i i smile at
all my pictures now
because these pictures they have them
for the rest of their lives
and and they show them to their friends
their family
um
and what do you want do you want
that or do you want
oh he's a nice guy or oh he's an [ __ ]
he couldn't even you couldn't even smile
he looked so serious he didn't look like
he didn't want you want to be there
you know that's one thing i've learned
it's very important
being
in the public eye
you have to give people time
and you have to be happy about it
uh
because
you know one encounter
is not just one encounter
if you meet somebody you're actually
meeting their friends
their family their son their daughters
you know that one person it's a spider
web
so that one person is actually
a thousand different people and it's
either gonna be
he was a really good guy he was a cool
guy he said he took he took a picture
and he spent you know he spent time and
talked to me
that's that's the story that goes out to
the thousand people or
what an [ __ ] what a wanker
um
which one of those stories do you want
being
spider webbed out into the universe you
know and it all comes back around
because you meet the friends you meet
the family you see the tweet yeah you
see the tweets you know it all comes
back around so
good energy positive vibes give people
your time you know
because those pictures and those stories
stay with them for the rest of their
lives
and becomes your karma
and becomes your karma it becomes
how people treat you that you've never
met before
you know you really got to be aware of
the power of your energy towards other
people if if you give off bad vibes and
then you get bad vibes if you're a good
person if you give people time
it all comes back around
there's been this kind of perception
because of that because if you're very
stone-faced that you're unemotional
sure you've heard this before
yeah
what's the truth in there are you
unemotional
i've heard that i've heard that word
many times
throughout the years with girls i've
dated
that's always been a really
bad or hard thing for them to
to get past is that i'm not
an emotional guy
apparently i'm very hard to read
when i'm in a relationship or on a date
or whatever it is um you know they don't
know if i even like them
um
am i emotional no i'm not
i have emotions obviously but
you know like
for you to upset me
is it's damn near impossible
and you know i will never sh i i don't
think i've
i can't remember the last time i shouted
at somebody
i don't have that emotion to
you know if you if you do something
wrong to me or to disrespect me or
okay
and then i just never see you again
i i don't get that like
you know what are you doing you know
like that so many people get i don't
have that in me i don't know why
you know if i knock somebody out in the
ring
i stand there
i look at them while they're on the
floor that's it
you know 99.9 percent of fighters they
they knock a guy out
[Music]
jumping up onto the brink
high fiving people
crying
you know i don't i don't have that
emotion it's like yeah i knocked you out
this is what i said i was gonna do this
is what i've trained for
for my whole life
so
yeah that's what happened
um
do you ever worry though that that's
gonna get in your way a little bit in
terms of especially romantic
relationships women
are a little bit more emotional than men
um they're more in touch with their
feelings i mean the data shows that
quite clearly so
do you ever think that's gonna inhibit
you from forming romantic relationships
i mean i've never really thought about
it and it's not
because she said you wanted kids i
remember hearing you say that of course
yeah i mean who doesn't
um well i mean some people don't but
eventually i do want a kid
but you know
the woman i'm going to have a kid with
is not going to be a woman that needs an
emotional man you know some women don't
need that
um was your father emotional
no
no your mother
yeah
yeah father emotional at all
no
affectionate
i knew he loved me and that you know i
knew i could i knew he wanted the best
for me
um
[Music]
he was emotional enough to for me to
know that
uh that's my dad and i would do anything
for him and i love him you know some
some people don't have that relationship
with their dads you know
i love my dad i res but i respected him
and i feared him
um
i did fear him
so
and that was you know he was very strict
growing up i couldn't get away with
anything
i think that's sometimes about myself i
think you know i i actually grew up i
still to this day called my mum and dad
by their first names never called them
mum and dad and then i think there was a
lack of affection and emotion in my
child in my childhood so
i had to kind of learn
growing up how to be affectionate and
emotional i remember someone calling me
their best friend and me feeling this
like internal
repulsion like the [ __ ]
and then when i would when i'd get into
a relationship with well no this was
even worse when i'd find someone that i
fancied and i'd pursue them the minute
they showed interest in me i'd reject
them and so until i realized that was
going on and i had this like weird thing
in me it controlled me and it meant that
27 i had my first proper relationship
so
yeah that's uh i'd learn a bad model of
affection relationships and emotions so
i feel like i've become a little bit
more emotional as i've gotten older
you know before
nothing could phase me you know doesn't
matter what would happen nothing would
phase me
up until a few years maybe maybe over
the last like two or three years
there's been a few times where i've
watched movies
and
i'd get this like
you know something sad would happen and
i'd get this this feeling you know like
and i i never cried you know but
you know that like that start of like i
might cry
um
[Music]
and i was like what what the hell is
this you know like this is weird and
that's only have started happening over
the last couple of years
so i don't know if i'm becoming more
mellow
or
i don't know but i'm just i'm just not
an emotional person you know i haven't
cried
you know the last time i well i was the
last time i cried i was
i was 12 years old
and then i cried again when my brother
died last year
so
you know that's
that's 20 years in 20 years i've cried
once
so yeah i mean i guess you could say i'm
not emotional but that's what i needed
to be
to do the things i've done in the ring
that that that was that was my journey
that was that was how i was able to do
it
um i had to get my emotions out
to be able to perform
ice cold
you know some guys use their emotions to
help them fight more
that was my path you know if i ever
if i ever felt emotions getting involved
in you know whether it was hate or anger
or
being afraid i would
i noticed that it affected my fighting
negatively i would make mistakes
you know if i went into a sparring
session i really didn't like the guy
you know and i went out there and really
tried to hurt him i'd actually hurt him
less than if i was just cool calm cold
and calculated you know
i'd make mistakes i'd attack when i
wasn't supposed to attack or i would
i'd move and i would do certain things
which i'm just i'm only doing because i
just want to get him you know and it's
like
boxing is a chess match you know
at the highest levels
you have to think about everything that
you're doing
the guys that think while they're in the
ring not just react those are the guys
who who make it to
the top of the top
have you ever had this conversation with
your father about your emotions
about dealing with emotions suppressing
emotions whatever because
i don't know i struggle to believe that
you're not emotional as you've seen you
does come out in you but it just seems
like you've
learned how to
suppress and not express those emotions
i have never had this conversation with
my father no we've never talked about
emotions or
feelings
i'm not gonna say he's not that type of
guy because he actually may be now at
this stage in his life
you know he's he's found god he's very
religious now
um
so maybe i actually could have this
conversation with him but
you know
10 years ago
20 years ago
there's just no way i could never sit
down with him and
and talk about my feelings you know
he'd be like feelings
come let me take my belt off and show
you about feelings you know
really
it was not you know very strict very um
[Music]
yeah very
uh
you you i got away with nothing as a kid
you know but i i think i needed that
because i was very boisterous i was very
i had a lot of energy
you know i got myself into this gang
when i was a kid and
you know i was going around i was
fighting i was
you know skipping school um
[Music]
the only thing that
somewhat kept me in line
was knowing that if i got caught or if i
went too far
my dad was waiting for me at home
do you really think he would have taken
his belt off if you tried to chat with
him back through here i'm exactly i'm
exaggerating that part yeah but listen
the belt came off many times
but when i stepped out of line as a kid
yeah
um
you know that strictness those that
punishment
uh
stopped me from
going even more overboard than i already
did
and i did go overboard you know you can
go on to youtube right now and see a
video of me street fighting at 16 years
old in the car park in brighton
and i was doing that every other week
you know
so imagine what i would have been doing
if i could if i could just have free
reign if i had nothing
stopping me from doing anything it would
you
know i'd be in jail
100 percent
um
[Music]
you know we're jamaicans we're built
differently you know we're
there's just something in our dna which
uh you know we
we we have this thing where we
you know we we like to cause trouble man
i don't know why
um
my father was the same you know he got
into all types of trouble as a kid you
know stealing and
getting arrested and fighting you know
that's just
i don't know we just we we come from a a
bloodline of
of uh of ruffians you know it's just how
we are
i'm a lot more
um
refined now as an adult you know i look
back at some of the things i was doing
and i'm just like
what what was i thinking i remember
i went to college
for maybe
a month or two before i ended up moving
to america
some kid from
this uh the school that was opposite
from the college had had somehow gotten
my number
and i had i got in a fight with his
brother and these are these two really
big kids um and he he got my he called
me like 2am woke me up he's like yo who
do you think you are
i'm gonna [ __ ] you i'm gonna do this i'm
gonna eat you i'm gonna do this stuff to
you
you know watch wait till i find you
watch hung up the phone
i i knew who the kid was because i heard
i knew his voice right
the next day
i went into school with a baseball bat
in in my gym bag
so i have the gym bag so obviously no
one can see it
lunch bar rang went picked up my bag
started walking across to the other
school
to find this kid
and when i say find him i mean like
i was walking in and out of classes
i was opening the doors
and seeing
you know the teachers looking like
who are you what are you doing don't
worry about it so i was walking from
classroom to classroom to classroom to
classroom on your own on my own yeah to
find this kid
with the baseball bat in my bag and you
know
um
i thank god i thank the good lord above
that i didn't find him
that i didn't see him
because you know
i walk into a classroom or i see him on
the football field i take the baseball
bat out i hit him with it
finished
you know one i could kill the kid
i'm in jail for the rest of my life
um
you know
i would i would have been banned from
going to america
so my my whole
my whole foundation
uh everything that i learned going over
to the states as as
at 18 years old having my first amateur
fights training with floyd mayweather
and his father
that would have all been washed away i
would have never i would have never done
it
so i would never have done anything in
boxing because that was that was that
start
was what built me up
you know
you know i just so i just thank god that
he wasn't there that day because that
could have changed the part of my life
you know and i just look back at that
like
how what were you thinking like how
stupid could you be but obviously as a
kid you you're not thinking about
consequences or america you know you you
know you're just upset that some kid
called you up and and called you an
[ __ ] and said he's gonna mess you up
the next time you see him you're not
thinking about
traveling and getting bands and going to
prison and you're just thinking i want
to be a big man and and show everyone
i'm hard
you know so it's just
you know you have to have that's why i
say i thank god for my father as well
for how strict he was because
you know
there were other times where there were
things that i was going to do
but i didn't do them because i didn't
want to
suffer the consequences of my old man
so um
yeah
you talked earlier about your the death
of your brother
sebastian
the first time i went to dubai
i went to the gym there
and there was a young guy there that
came over and offered to train me
and he trained me for
about
i think two weeks
individually i was your brother
got loads of photos hundreds and
hundreds of photos of him training me on
the bags there
i remember him as being just the most
generous
pure
pure is the word that i always come back
to
giving person he did not ask me for any
money he never asked me for a thing he
trained me on the bags both times that i
came to um
dubai and i wasn't he didn't necessarily
know who i was or what i was doing but
he did that out of the goodness of his
heart and then he continued to message
me and speak to him on instagram about
superfoods and we talked a lot about
that
obviously he there was a tragic accident
and he
passed away from that
what can you tell me about that incident
and the
lasting impact that's had on you and
those those around you
i mean you know
this is fresh this is this only happened
a year ago
um
and i never had to
i've never dealt with anything like that
in my life
um
i told you i'm not an emotional guy
the last time i cried i said i was 12
years old
but the day i found out
i cried the whole day
i cried the whole day i cried for like
two days straight
um
yeah yeah my so my dad actually
i had covered i had covered when i found
my dad came to my house
uh
he woke me up
he said come outside
and i thought i'd done something wrong
because he had he had a look in his face
which was uh
i don't know i just couldn't i can't
describe it but it was
i knew something was wrong
um so i thought that you know i don't
know i i i wasn't sure what what i was
about to hear he took me outside my
little brother my little brother joseph
um
he's he lives with me and i have an
outhouse
uh so he lives there he went and got him
and he sat us down and he told us and um
you know i just started crying man it
was you know one of the worst days of my
life and um
you know
it's just it's so crazy to to think that
somebody that is so healthy you know
like you said he's telling you about the
superfoods and
you know he trains every day you know
peak physical condition
um
can just you know have a heart attack
and just gone
just still just blows my mind you know
um
i thank god that you know he didn't
suffer he didn't he didn't really feel
anything he just went
um and i also thank god that he had a
son
his son was born
maybe a month or month before he passed
and he raheem
and he looks just like him
so we have that you know
um we have raheem to carry on his legacy
and i thank god for that every day um
you know he's just now starting to walk
learning how to walk
he has a seven or eight teeth he's he's
a great kid
very good looking kid
um
i guess
that one
instance
i feel like that has made me more of an
emotional person since that's happened
um
it makes you think just like how
before something that happens to you you
hear about all that stuff on your news
and to other people and you see it in
movies
and it's just like well whatever you
know it doesn't it doesn't really
register but when there's a death in
your family then
then the next time you hear about
someone passing away then you get that
immediate feeling of what you dealt with
and then you start to sympathize and
empathize and
with the people that it's happening to
that you don't know
um and i never had that emotion before
until until this happened um
and it just you know
like i said i had covid
and
uh
that meant that i actually couldn't make
it to his his funeral which is
you know it's just crazy like i was in
florida for the whole of covert right
and
when i say that these guys didn't care
in florida like
the beaches were full
no one's wearing masks i i remember
going to the beach and i would walk
along the beach thousands of people and
i'd be wearing a mask this was like peak
covered and people would be looking at
me like what are you wearing a mask for
like they did not care
i was in i went to texas i was in dallas
for a month i was partying every night
never got covered
and then
the day my brother dies i have covered
and i can't get on a plane
and fly to dubai for his funeral because
i have covered and
in the muslim
religion they have to bury him as
quickly as possible
um
they couldn't wait
i thank god that my family were able to
go out
i had to stay
um
you know i don't
i don't believe in regrets
um
i believe what's meant you know what's
meant to be will be
and you know you should be happy with
whatever happens in your life you know
but i would say there is one regret i
have in my life
uh and that was
i actually went so i hadn't i hadn't
seen my brother for quite some time
and
uh
i was
i had a holiday this was i don't know
maybe three or four months before he
passed away i stopped off i had to stop
off in dubai and i stopped off in dubai
for like a couple days before i flew to
this destination
and um
i didn't want to i didn't want to see
anybody
nobody knew that i was making this trip
i knew my brother was in dubai and i
didn't go and see him
i just i didn't want people knowing i
was in dubai so i just i stayed in my
hotel room and i didn't see anybody
and then i left and i went to the next
destination
that's that's probably the one regret i
have in my life now is that i didn't
go and see him you know because that
would have
that would have been the last time i
would have saw him before he passed
um
[Music]
you know and these things it just
teaches you you've got to appreciate
and you've gotta
um
you know you don't take anything for
granted nothing is guaranteed you know
the people you love
be with them as much as you can
appreciate them enjoy them
don't get into fights
you know
don't do things which just wasting time
because
one minute they're there and one minute
they're gone and then you've got to
think about all the things you could
have done with them or should have done
with them that you didn't because
you know you're
you're too busy or you you know i'll see
them again another time
you know it's uh it's crazy how the
world works but yeah
i appreciate everyone at all times and
you know
family is family is number one
you know
don't let anything ever get in between
that don't take it for granted that's
one thing i've learned
you know investing a lot of time in your
relationship with rheem
absolutely yeah we're on the phone all
the time
i've got a million videos of him
on my phone my my uh my brother's wife
seb's wife salma she send me videos
every day of raheem
um
they're coming over to england actually
in uh in a month or so
and yeah so raheem is is now my son you
know that's that's how i feel
um
you know it actually makes me want to
have a kid
i was never really planning on having a
kid until after my career
and i still may not but
um
i want raheem to be able to grow up with
my son you know i don't want them to be
too
far apart
um
you know me and my brother said we were
you know a year and a half apart so we
were very close you know we did
everything together
um so i want i want raheem to have that
so you know within the next few years
we'll uh we'll see what happens
one of the things i couldn't quite
ascertain from
googling
was if you uh if you are in a
relationship or if you're dating you
keep all that stuff very private i don't
blame you to feel this but
i couldn't quite ascertain where you're
at with that um
most things said you weren't
but is it
a part of your life
absolutely yeah
one thing i've learned is that
relationships and social media don't mix
um
i've just i've seen social media mess up
so many relationships
uh that i just
you know i decided a long time ago that
whoever i was with
uh is not gonna be
it's not gonna be a public relationship
my life is public
people can see what i'm doing every day
i want something that's for me
uh
you know and you've got so many girls
out there who
you know they're they're just clout
chasers you know they they just want
they want to say that you know that look
at me look at these pictures we went
here we went there
um i don't need that in my life you know
i've got enough clout i've got enough
attention on me so i
i keep my private life private
so much so that i've actually seen
comments online saying that i'm gay
you know
this guy's never in pictures with girls
he's never gotten he's got no girls on
his instagram i think he's gay i've seen
that like multiple times and just you
know i laugh my ass off whenever i see
that but
yeah i just
i just don't i don't believe in mixing
the two i don't i don't see any
positives from it you know people see
something
if they see something
if they see people happy
some most people yeah that's great but
there's there's a large p percentage of
people that if they're seeing something
happy they they want to try and make it
unhappy that's what is as crazy as that
sounds that's what some people do you
know
so uh
i'm not gonna let anybody take shots at
or try and
muddy my relationship because
i've seen it happen before it will you
know and it happened it happens all the
time
i believe
a private life should be private and
that's that's how i've chosen to
to keep my relationships
it's good to hear i agree
i'm not gay
you talked a bit about um seb there and
his approach to like health and fitness
i actually looked back through my
conversations with him before you came
and all of our conversations were about
health and fitness he'd asked me a few
things about social media and some
advice there but
did that incident also impact how you
viewed the health implications of the
sport that you do
because you know you can get
one
one hit in boxing and it can be it can
cause really bad damage right
has that brought it more into the
spotlight for you that your the
fragility of your health and
you know i hear a lot of boxers talk
about not overstaying their welcome
tyson fury this weekend after he won the
fight talked about that as well
has that is that front of mind for you
when you you think about your career
i wouldn't say that what happened with
seb has
um
no it hasn't hasn't affected how i think
about boxing um
you know i've been doing this game i've
been in this game for a long time
i've been in fights where you know
i've hurt people to the point where they
you know have been in a coma i've fought
a a man named nick blackwell
years back and you know he
he uh he got taken to hospital he
actually died on the way to hospital and
he had to revive him with an adrenaline
shot and he was in a coma for two weeks
um you know that that was national news
um
you know those types of instance of
incidents are what
really put things into perspective and
make you think about what you're doing
and
the risks and the implications
as a youngster you don't think about it
you know when something like that
happens then you do think about it and
you and you think about even more as you
get older
because as you get older
especially in boxing you
you're affected more by the punishment
you take
i feel like when i was young it's like i
could do anything and i never get hurt
you know at 32
you know you pick up sick little
injuries and
you know you
the shots you take you feel them that
little bit more than you used to
you start forgetting things
you know
um do you think that's correlated that
forgetting things
so what you'd forget like a name or
something and you'd yeah and you'd like
my recall is is a lot worse than it used
to be
so
you know in my 20s
um
if i couldn't remember something i'd sit
there
and within five seconds i get it you
know you do that thing when you think
about it oh yeah yeah
now it's
ten minutes
you know i i it's it's it's really
embarrassing to say but
i forgot the name of somebody one time
it took me a week
every day sitting there
like throughout the day whenever i would
remember what was the name what was the
name and then a week later bang just
came to me
i just i couldn't i was just nuts you
know because now
now i force myself to remember
because it's like you're training your
brain it's called recall
so i'll i'll force myself if i'm if i
you know i could easily just go on my
phone and what was the name again google
oh yeah that was it
but now i now i force myself to pull it
out of my mind
um and that there was one particular
name and it took me a whole week before
it just snapped back
do you have recall apps on your phone i
read that somewhere that you had like a
an app on your phone to help you train
so i have an app now it's called um
elevate
and it's basically
going to the gym but for your brain
you know so i've got here so you've got
like
spelling recall eloquence precision
um
you know you have it's games it's games
that you play you know vocabulary
uh math equations you know just little
games to play each day and it just keeps
your mind working
your mind your brain is like a muscle
you know if you keep using it the more
you use it the better it gets right the
stronger it gets and i think it's
important you know especially because as
you get older you you know i do i know i
notice it you know i'll i'll
go into a room and i'll put my phone
down somewhere
and then i'll walk off and then i'll
and i'll walk around the room looking
for the bloody phone
it's you know and it's like i'm think it
shouldn't this should not be happening
um
[Music]
is that from
getting hit in the head i don't know is
it just i'm getting no i don't know
um sounds like me to be honest and i
don't get hit in the head i don't drink
you know you know i got i got friends
they drink every night
you know and they're very smart guys you
know they're in business they're in
economics they're you know they
they're in tech they
but
they drink
a lot sometimes so it's like and i feel
like you know
drinking kills brain cells right
just like a punch would
but they seem to be okay i don't know so
maybe maybe that maybe that impact is is
just it's just different i don't know
i am so excited to announce our new
sponsor for this podcast and that is
blue jeans by verizon for any of you
that aren't already familiar with blue
jeans they are a video conferencing and
collaboration tool who offer an
immersive communication experience that
drives pretty unparalleled employee and
customer engagement experiences me and
all of my teams across all of my
portfolio companies switched over to
blue jeans a couple of months ago and we
have not looked back the best thing for
us has been the totally frictionless
experience no glitching no sound issues
no delays or any of those things that
usually make virtual meetings really
really frustrating we use blue jeans
anywhere on any device at any time and
it's perfect for my small businesses
that just have 10 or 20 people to some
of my bigger businesses that have
hundreds of people i'm a big fan as you
can probably tell so i've been quite
excited for for some time to announce
this partnership and in the coming weeks
i'll explain the features and really why
it's perfect for you if you haven't
considered using or switching over to
blue jeans yet but if you can't wait
head over to bluejeans.com to learn more
honestly it's been one of the real sort
of game changers in my business
we talked about feelings earlier
right um
and how
there's been a lot of sort of
generational changes around men
expressing their feelings
and one of the big changes i think i've
seen in the last 10 years from 10 years
ago when i was well for 19 to now is
this topic of mental health and men and
i think it's really been pushed to the
forefront because the stats around
mental health in our country
you know you've heard them we've all
heard them that the biggest killer of
men under the age of 45 is themselves
and a lot of people point and go well
why is that a lot of the mental health
charities cite that men don't express
themselves enough they're not emotional
they don't talk and we've had all the
campaigns about talking and
um those kinds of things have you ever
experienced
anxiety or depression
or any sort of mental health um
ailment
that's one thing that i do thank god for
is that i've never experienced any of
that
um
it's hard for me to relate to
uh hearing about people with depression
and
anxiety like i've just never experienced
anything like that um i know it's a
thing
um
[Music]
but i'm i'm just an extremely happy and
content person and i'm not saying that
to you know pick myself up that's just
how i am it's like it doesn't matter
what happens i'll find
the bright side or
if there's something bad going on in my
life i'm
i'm able to just cut it off
and move on
deal with it to the to where it stops
being an issue
um i've i've never been the type of
person that will let something affect me
um
you know from day one in my career
i've had i've been i've been a target
i get a serious amount of
[ __ ] online to this day
uh
haters doubters non-believers
i have like a whole army dedicated to
just
sticking it to me on a daily basis
online it's unbelievable
um
and the funny thing is if i walk out
into the street it's pictures it's
autographs it's love
none of these guys are around
why is that
i
you know i i got it at the beginning
well actually i didn't get it at the
beginning it really got to me because
you know i'm young i'm coming into the
game i'm trying to be the you know
trying to do the best i can
and i've got people constantly coming at
me oh you think you're you're old man
you're a copycat you'll never be as good
as him
uh you're a wannabe
you know and when i when i saw when i
first started experiencing this uh
this hatred and this um
you know this trolling
it did affect me
um
i didn't get depressed
because i'm not that type of person but
angry
you know why are these people saying
these things what what have i done to
them
um i couldn't understand it you know
maybe that is why i had for so many
years that kind of
that stone wall when i was taking
pictures of doing interviews
because i'd seen so much
so much negativity online you know um
but then after a while
i i don't know it just it just switched
one day and i was just like
why am i getting upset why am i getting
pissed off with these random guys
i don't i know what it was some guy
wrote something uh i think on my
facebook
i think i just had a fight and he said
um
terrible performance you're an
embarrassment to your family name
i hope you get knocked out in your next
fight you scumbag
right
i'm i'm a 22 year old kid
i've got some and you know i'm looking
i'm like jesus like you know it's just
nuts
i clicked on his
profile i was like i've got to see who
said this i mean who is this guy he must
be some amazing guy to be
saying this to me
and uh
you know it was this
fat
bloated
just nobody you and he was sitting on
his couch with a with a beer that was
his profile picture and he ended and he
had his cat next to him and he was in
shorts and like a wife beer
um or what you guys don't say wifi
that's my american thing coming out uh
tank top
um
and i was like hold on this is the guy
that just called me a scumbag
i'm letting this guy
affect my day
nah nah this has got to stop
and from that day on i just realized
it's not it's not even me it's
they're unhappy with themselves they're
not happy with me
you know the people that are trolling
you know they've got whatever they've
got going on in their lives they're
upset they're unhappy
they and they're projecting that onto
other people who are
who they see as doing them doing well
for themselves and they you know oh he's
look at him he's you know he's got all
that and you know let me see if i can
bring him down you know i'm upset so let
me see if i can make him upset like
that sounds crazy to me to do that but
that's
what i've come to understand that some
people do
you know they're unhappy so they want to
make other people unhappy with them
as soon as i realized that
i i never i never worried about trolling
or bad comments again i actually and now
i actually enjoy them you also must know
that it's profitable for you
absolutely mayweather taught us that
absolutely yeah i mean in in boxing
that's another that's another thing
which made me stop worrying about it
because i knew
after a while i started i started seeing
these trolls at my fights
you know i'd be walking to the ring
you're gonna get knocked out what are we
i'd hear all this stuff walking to the
ring
right
and i thought hold on a second
that guy bought a ticket
he paid to be there to to shout at me as
i walked past
and i'm you know
i'm getting a percentage of that ticket
what am i upset about all right he
shouted at me but
i've just made some money off the guy
so then then i understood right
you have to be a villain
or you have to be a
a hero in the sport of boxing
love or hate you can't be in the middle
i have a lot of fans
and i have a lot of haters both buy
their tickets
both
buy their pay-per-view subscription
to watch on tv
both get online and talk
and build the profile
the guys that are in the middle they're
the guys who don't do well because
when you're neutral in the spot of
boxing people don't tune in they don't
talk they're not interested it doesn't
matter how good of a fight you are if
you're not a character that can
inspire emotion whether good or bad
then on a saturday night when you get
into the ring
you know the people will be sitting
there
when they get off work or wherever they
are
oh yeah he's fighting tonight but
there's this really hot girl and she's
going to be at this club
yeah i'm going to go to the club i'll
watch the replay or i'll just i'll find
out what happened the next day yeah i
don't need to
that's what happens when you're neutral
or when people aren't really that
interested
if they hate you
forget the forget the girl in the club
i'm going to that fight to see him get
knocked out
let's go
let's go
forget everything else and if they love
you
forget the girl in the club i want to be
there when he wins
those are the guys love and hate that
will tune in that will watch you every
fight that will talk about you
so that's one thing i learned early on
you have to be you you have to be a
character you have to be something that
people can either get behind or get
against
and that's very much i feel what i am
um
at the beginning most people were
against me
because they saw me as a gimmick as
somebody was just trying to make a quick
buck use my name to get a better profile
have a few fights and then probably go
on love island or big brother or
whatever it is and you know whatever
but then obviously as the years went by
win after win after win
a lot of the haters turned into fans
um
there's still a lot of haters left but
you know we're working our way to making
them into fans
uh slowly but surely
quick one we bring in eight people a
month to watch these conversations live
here in the studio when we're here in
the uk and when we're in la if you want
to be one of those people all you've got
to do is hit subscribe
do you feel like your career is complete
and if the answer is no
what do you think is required in terms
of your boxing career
with the knowledge that as you said
before we started that there is a window
of time where you you get to do this and
you get to do at the highest level
what is required if the answer is no to
make you feel that your your career was
complete
it's an absolute no um
i've had a lot of great fights i've had
a lot of great wins but
um
there's still so much more left you know
there's still so many more big fights
out there for me to to take part in and
to win
um
you know i want to capture these world
titles
you know i've been a world champion at
super middleweight i'm back down at
middleweight now
um
and you know the the
you know the map is wide open there's
there's a lot of great fighters and they
have belts and i i can get in with these
guys and i can beat these guys
um
you know boxing you do have a short
window
but i live my life
uh correctly i live the boxing lifestyle
boxing is not just a sport it is a
lifestyle
um
you know outside of a fight camp
i'm not drinking i'm not doing drugs
uh
i'm not overeating and blowing up in
weight which so many fighters do
and then they have to spend weeks or
months cutting that weight back off to
make
whatever weight they're going to be at
on fight night i don't do any of that i
stay in the gym
i stay dedicated i stay healthy
i stay responsible
so that being said
i will be able to fight until
i will be able to fight effectively and
i would say until i'm 37 38 39 years old
um i'm 32 now
you know my father retired at they too
i'm so i'm retirement isn't even close
to what i'm thinking about
you know i am financially stable
but there's still so much more money out
there to be made
there's still so much more accolades out
there to collect
um and i still have a lot left in the
tank so
to answer your question no my career is
not
um complete
far from it even even though i've had 34
fights you know
more fights than a lot of fighters have
had and 32 wins is still not complete
there's still so much more i'm gonna do
and the next few years
are the money years and they are the
years where i need to fight the best
beat the best
and really cement my legacy
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest asks the
next guest a question they never know
who they're writing it for
they said hello which is the first time
anyone said hello but
hello i was wondering
what you believe happiness is
and how it can be achieved
um
well as i said before i'm an extremely
happy person i may not look it at times
but i'm very content
um
i don't get angry i don't shout i don't
put other people down
i don't wish bad on other people
um if someone's successful if someone's
doing better than me
i look up to that
i praise that i respect that
you know
other people they see people succeeding
or doing better than them and they think
oh you know
i wish he would trip up
you know why has he got all that why is
why is she doing that and i can't do it
don't be like that
you can never be happy if you're
constantly comparing yourself to other
people and
you know
not wanting the best for everybody
including yourself
you know it's a mirror life's a mirror
you know
whatever you're projecting is is
projected back to you if you if if
you're negative that's what your life is
going to be
and that's whether it's thoughts so
that's whether it's tweets that's
whether it's what you're saying to
people
everything comes back around
you know
so happiness is
is positivity
is being a good person
is being a genuine person
um
you know don't lie to people
if if you think something's wrong say it
you know if you if you think that
somebody's doing something wrong or
that they're on the wrong path help them
because you're helping yourself
you know
be positive that's the key to happiness
chris thank you for doing this it's been
a huge honor and i can't wait to see
what you do over the next couple of
years
in your money years
in and outside of the ring
and i thank you for giving me the
opportunity because yeah there's not a
lot of people that that do get to see
this side of me you know all they see is
the big bad guy in the ring he's
throwing punches you know
i don't do a lot of interviews like this
so yeah i appreciate you uh putting me
on here and
hopefully the fans get to see a
different side
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete the
salted caramel one if you put some ice
cubes in it and you put it in a blender
and you try it is as good as pretty much
any milkshake on the market just mixed
with water it's been a game changer for
me because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you for
making a product that i actually like as
you might know crafted are one of the
sponsors of this podcast and crafted are
a jewelry brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewelry and this
piece by crafted when i put it on for me
it represents courage it represents
ambition it represents being calm and
loving and respectful and nurturing
while also being the antithesis of that
seemingly the antithesis of that which
is um sometimes a little bit aggressive
with my goals and determined and
courageous and brave the really
wonderful thing about crafted jewelry is
it's super affordable it looks amazing
the pieces hold tremendous meaning and
they are really well made
[Music]
[Music]
you